ah romantic love beautiful and
intoxicating heartbreaking and
soul-crushing often all at the same time
why do we choose to put ourselves
through its emotional wringer does love
make our lives meaningful or is it an
escape from our loneliness and suffering
is love a disguise for our sexual desire
or a trick of biology to make us
procreate is it all we need do we need
it at all if romantic love has a purpose
neither science nor psychology has
discovered it yet but over the course of
history some of our most respected
philosophers have put forward some
intriguing theories love makes us whole
again the ancient Greek philosopher
Plato explored the idea that we love in
order to become complete in his
symposium he wrote about a dinner party
at which Aristophanes a comic playwright
regales the guests with the following
story humans were once creatures with
four arms four legs and two faces one
day they angered the gods and Zeus
sliced them all in tune since then every
person has been missing half of him or
herself love is the longing to find a
soulmate who will make us feel whole
again or at least that's what Plato
believed a drunken comedian would say at
a party love tricks us into having
babies much much later German
philosopher Arthur Schopenhauer
maintained that love based in sexual
desire was a voluptuous illusion he
suggested that we love because our
desires lead us to believe that another
person will make us happy but we are
sorely mistaken
nature is tricking us into procreating
and the loving fusion we seek is
consummated in our children when our
sexual desires are satisfied we are
thrown back into our tormented
existences and we succeed only in
maintaining the species and perpetuating
the cycle of human drudgery sounds like
somebody needs a hug
love is escape from our loneliness
according to the Nobel prize-winning
British philosopher Bertrand Russell we
love in order to quench our physical and
psychological desires humans are
designed to procreate but without the
ecstasy of passion and love sex is
unsatisfying our fear of the cold cruel
world tempts us to build hard shells to
protect and isolate ourselves loves
delight intimacy and warmth helps us
overcome our fear of the world escape
our lonely shells and engage more
abundantly in life love enriches our
whole being making it the best thing in
life love is a misleading affliction
siddhartha gautama who became known as
the Buddha or the enlightened one
probably would have had some interesting
arguments with russell buddha proposed
that we love because we are trying to
satisfy our base desires yet our
passionate cravings our defects and
attachments even romantic love are a
great source of suffering
luckily buddha discovered the Eightfold
Path a sort of program for extinguishing
the fires of desire so that we can reach
nirvana an enlightened state of peace
clarity wisdom and compassion
the novelist Chow chouette Qin
illustrated this Buddhist sentiment that
romantic love is folly in one of China's
greatest classical novels dream of the
red chamber in a subplot Jaa rahe falls
in love with Shi Feng who tricks and
humiliates him conflicting emotions of
love and hate tear him apart
so a Taoist gives him a magic mirror
that can cure him as long as he doesn't
look at the front of it but of course he
looks at the front of it he sees Shi
Feng his soul enters the mirror and he
is dragged away in iron chains to die
not all Buddhists think this way about
romantic and erotic love but the moral
of this story is that such attachments
spell tragedy and should along with
magic mirrors be avoided love lets us
reach beyond ourselves
let's end on a slightly more positive
note the French philosopher Simone de
Beauvoir proposed that love is the
desire to integrate with another and
that it infuses our lives with meaning
however she was less concerned with why
we love and more interested in how we
can love better she saw that the problem
with traditional romantic love is it can
be so captivating that we are tempted to
make it our only reason for being
yet dependence on another to justify our
existence easily leads to boredom and
power games to avoid this trap Beauvoir
advised loving authentically which is
more like a great friendship
lovers support each other in discovering
themselves reaching beyond themselves
and enriching their lives and the world
together though we might never know why
we fall in love we can be certain that
it'll be an emotional roller coaster
ride it's scary and exhilarating it
makes us suffer and makes us soar maybe
we lose ourselves maybe we find
ourselves it might be heartbreaking or
it might just be the best thing in life
will you dare to find out
you